which do you believe is the most  important  to produce enough nutritious affordable  food  for every person or protect the future  of our planet we don't believe  we should have to choose as the european  green deal sets out to make europe  the world's first climate neutral  continent  farm to fork is at its heart  investing billions of euros into  research and technologies  transforming how we produce distribute  and consume our food for healthy people  healthy societies and a healthy planet  and at the same time creating new  opportunities for consumers  farmers and the food industry it's time  to reshape tomorrow  to move from an ideal to a reality  from a way of eating to a way of  life from farm to fork  [Music]  do you have the appetite for change  you